Hey, everybody, Ira Glass here. So we've been working on today's episode of the radio show for a while, and the theme of the episode is "Tarred and Feathered." And initially, we just assumed we'd be using the phrase "tarred and feathered" as a metaphor for when somebody is shamed publicly.
大家好，我是艾拉·格拉斯。我们一直在筹备今天这期电台节目，主题是“柏油与羽毛”（Tarred and Feathered，意指被当众羞辱）。起初，我们只是想把这个短语作为一种隐喻，形容某人当众出丑。
But then we read a news report about a guy named Jock Nelson, who actually was tarred and feathered. Somebody poured tar on him and then stuck feathers to the tar, and not in the year 1850 or something. This was in 2007, seven years ago, in Belfast in Northern Ireland.
但随后我们读到了一篇关于一个叫乔克·尼尔森的人的新闻报道，他真的遭遇了柏油与羽毛的惩罚。有人把柏油浇在他身上，然后粘上羽毛。这可不是发生在1850年什么的，这是在2007年，七年前，发生在北爱尔兰的贝尔法斯特。
Where did it happen? Was it just around that corner?
事情发生在什么地方？就在那个街角吗？
Just-- well-- 100 yards from here.
就在——嗯——离这儿100码的地方。
OK, so I'm looking over to where you're pointing. And there's a day nursery, the Scribbles Day Nursery.
好，我正看向你指的方向。那边有个日托中心，涂鸦日托中心（Scribbles Day Nursery）。
Jon Ronson, who appears on our show from time to time, happened to be going to Belfast this week and happens to be writing a book about public shaming. So we asked him to go check out where this happened, which, yes, was right in front of a daycare center.
乔恩·龙森，我们节目的常客，这周正好要去贝尔法斯特，而且恰好在写一本关于公众羞辱的书。所以我们请他去看看事发现场，没错，就在一家托儿所门前。
He was tied to a post. Was it that post right there that he was tied to, that lamp post?
他被绑在柱子上。是绑在那个柱子上吗，那根灯柱？
Yup. The woman actually wanted to beat him. And people were saying, well, you can't very well beat him. He's tied to a lamp post, and he's tarred and feathered. We can't really add insult to injury. Or injury to the insult, maybe I should say.
是的。其实那个女人想揍他。但人们说，别这样，你不能揍他。他被绑在灯柱上，还被浇了柏油、粘了羽毛。我们不能在伤口上撒盐了。或者说，不能在羞辱之上再施加伤害。
Jon is talking here to Jackie McDonald, who is one of the leaders of the UDA, the Ulster Defense Association, which is a paramilitary group. During all the years of troubles in Northern Ireland, the paramilitary groups were the ones who would beat people up. They'd shoot people on both sides of the conflict. And even though most of the violence ended with a ceasefire in the 1990s, those groups are still around. They still exist. Jon says that Jackie McDonald looks and dresses a lot like Pauly from The Sopranos .
乔恩在这里采访的是杰基·麦克唐纳，他是阿尔斯特防卫协会（UDA）的领导人之一，这是一个准军事组织。在北爱尔兰的动荡岁月里，准军事组织就是那些会殴打他人的人。他们会在冲突双方阵营里枪杀他人。尽管大多数暴力在90年代的停火协议后结束了，但这些组织依然存在。乔恩说，杰基·麦克唐纳的长相和打扮很像《黑道家族》里的保利。
Yeah, he had a big gold chain. He had thick, kind of Pauly hair. He had his shirt open, so you could see his chest hair. He had one of those leather jackets that tough guys wear.
对，他戴着一条粗金链子。头发是那种保利式的浓密发型。衬衫敞开着，能看到胸毛。他还穿着那种硬汉常穿的皮夹克。
Did his organization do the tarring and feathering?
他的组织干了这起柏油与羽毛的处罚吗？
Well, he kept on saying the community did it. But then when I pressed him, he said, well, we are the community leaders, the UDA, so yeah.
嗯，他一直说这是社区干的。但当我追问时，他说，好吧，我们是社区领导人，是UDA，所以，是的。
Was he there?
他在场吗？
Yeah.
在。
By the way, were you here the day that they--
顺便问一下，他们那天……的时候你在场吗？
I just happened to be walking past.
我只是刚好路过。
Now when he said that, the woman who was standing with him--
他说这话时，站在他旁边的那个女人——
A local.
一个当地人。
A local lady-- burst into silent laughter, which I found quite telling.
当地的一位女士——突然无声地笑了起来，我觉得这很有深意。
Now, people do all kinds of things in this world that might tick off a paramilitary group. So what does it take to get tarred and feathered? Like what exactly did this guy do?
在这个世界上，人们会做各种可能惹恼准军事组织的事。那么，到底要干什么才会遭到柏油与羽毛的惩罚？这家伙到底做了什么？
OK, well, according to the Daily Mail article that came out at the time, he'd been a bouncer in a city center bar. And he lost his job, and he was having marital difficulties. And so he started dealing drugs to children, according to the Daily Mail. And he was repeatedly told to stop, but he didn't stop. And then one day, word got around a local pub that he was dealing drugs to children in a park.
好吧，根据当时《每日邮报》的报道，他曾经是市中心酒吧的保安。他丢了工作，又遇到了婚姻问题。据《每日邮报》称，他开始向孩子们兜售毒品。他多次被警告停止，但他没停。直到有一天，当地一家酒吧传出消息，说他在公园里向孩子们卖毒品。
And then he was caught, literally, with bags of coke in his pocket.
然后，他被抓个正着，口袋里装着成袋的可卡因。
Well, why not just go to the police, if they caught the guy with the cocaine?
既然抓到了藏有可卡因的人，为什么不直接报警呢？
Right, well, Jackie told me why.
嗯，杰基告诉了我原因。
The police need evidence, and the police need-- there's technicalities out there. And too many times in the past when drug dealers have been reported, they go to court, and they're back doing the same thing the same night. So the community just thought it was more serious than  that. It had to be dealt with in a different way.
警察需要证据，而且警察需要……存在法律漏洞。过去很多次，毒贩被举报后送上法庭，结果当天晚上出来又重操旧业。所以社区认为这比那更严重。必须用不同的方式解决。
Right.
明白了。
We actually talked about having somewhere in the park where we could put-- what do you call it?
我们其实讨论过在公园里设个什么东西……你们叫它什么来着？
Like the stocks?
类似枷锁吗？
Exactly. The stocks. We were going to have them there as a deterrent.
没错，枷锁。我们本打算把它放在那儿作为威慑。
Wait, wait, wait. I'm just going to stop the tape. He's saying stocks, like in colonial America, like where people would have their hands sticking through wood things, and they would just bring in stocks?
等等，等等，让我停一下。他说枷锁，就像殖民地时期的美国那样，把人的手穿过木头，直接把枷锁带过来？
Yep. They were seriously considering bringing in stocks.
是的。他们真的考虑过带上枷锁。
I'm going to talk this over with the police. When they say but if somebody was put in the stocks, and there was people throwing eggs or tomatoes at them, the police would have to intervene. And I says, well, if the police intervene, then the eggs and the tomatoes would be thrown at the police. So we didn't want to create that sort of situation.
我会和警察谈谈这件事。当他们说，如果有人被关进枷锁，有人扔鸡蛋或西红柿，警察就必须介入。我说，如果警察介入，那鸡蛋和西红柿就会扔到警察身上。所以我们不想造成那种局面。
And in the end, they decided, OK, well, we'll tar and feather him.
最后，他们决定，好吧，就用柏油和羽毛惩罚他。
So what exactly happens when you're tarred and feathered? Like, how does it go?
那么，当遭遇柏油和羽毛惩罚时，具体会发生什么？流程是怎样的？
OK. So he was told to turn up at a certain hour. I think something like 11 o'clock in the morning on a Sunday morning.
好吧。他被告知在某个时间点出现。我想应该是周日上午11点左右。
Wait, wait. They told him we're going to tar and feather you. Like you got to show up on time?
等等，等等。他们告诉他，我们要用柏油和羽毛惩罚你。就像你必须按时出现一样？
They didn't mention the words "tarring and feathering." They just said, you have to show up. You have to show up on Sunday morning at 11 o'clock. And so he did. Yeah, I know. He would have been pretty certain that something bad was going to happen to him. Nonetheless, he turned up on the dot of 11, because if you turn up late, something worse would happen to you.
他们没提“柏油与羽毛”这几个字。他们只是说，你必须到场。你必须在周日上午11点赶到。他就真的去了。是的，我知道。他一定很清楚会有可怕的事情发生在他身上。尽管如此，他还是在11点准时出现了，因为如果你迟到，会有更糟的事等着你。
Back, during the troubles, this would happen all the time. People would be asked to show up like this, and then they would get beaten with iron bars or baseball bats. Or they would get shot through the knees or ankles or hands. The paramilitary groups administered all kinds of punishments. So the guy shows up, as requested.
在动荡时期，这种情况常有。人们会被要求这样现身，然后会被铁棍或棒球棍殴打。或者膝盖、脚踝或手被枪击。准军事组织执行各种惩罚。所以，那家伙按要求现身了。
And then what happened?
然后发生了什么？
He was tied up, and a placard put on him. And he was tarred and feathered.
他被绑住，身上挂了块牌子。然后被浇上柏油、粘上羽毛。
I asked them where they got the tar from. And they said, B and Q, which is the local DIY superstore. What's the American version of--
我问他们柏油是从哪儿弄来的。他们说，从B and Q，那是一家当地的家居建材超市。美国的对标店是……
That's like Home Depot.
那是家得宝（Home Depot）。
Yeah, Home Depot. Yeah, our Home Depot.
对，家得宝。没错，就是我们的家得宝。
Were the feathers brought over in like a big bag? Or was it pillows?
羽毛是大袋装过来的吗？还是枕头里的？
I think it was a pillow.
我想是一个枕头。
And would the pillow just have come from these houses just around here?
枕头是从这附近的人家拿的吗？
Well, if they had asked for pillows, they would get 100.
嗯，如果他们开口要枕头，能收到100个。
I don't know if you can tell what he just said. He said, if they asked for pillows, they would've gotten 100.
不知道你们能不能听出来刚才他说什么。他说，如果他们要枕头，就能收到100个。
You know, the local people were very annoyed at what this fellow had done.
要知道，当地人对这家伙干的事非常恼火。
There are pictures of what this guy looked like, once he was tarred and feathered. And they are shocking. We put one on our website, if you're curious. He barely looks like a person, like he's just this blob of black tar and white feathers. You can't see his face at all. It's like his whole head is covered. He looks like the Abominable Snowman or something, with a placard hanging around his neck that says, I'm a drug-dealing scumbag.
有这个家伙被浇上柏油和羽毛后的照片。看起来非常令人震惊。如果你好奇的话，我们把它贴在网站上了。他几乎看不出人样，就像一团黑色柏油和白色羽毛的混合体。你根本看不到他的脸。整个头都被覆盖了。他看起来像雪怪或者什么东西，脖子上挂着个牌子，写着：我是个兜售毒品的人渣。
So in the Daily Mail article that came out, that said that Jock Nelson screamed for mercy, as he was being tarred and feathered, that it was boiling tar, and that his shirt was pulled down over his shoulders so that it would burn. But Jackie says, it didn't happen quite that way and that Jock Nelson was fully clothed.
所以，《每日邮报》那篇报道说乔克·尼尔森在被惩罚时尖叫着求饶，说那是沸腾的柏油，他的衬衫被拉下肩膀，好让柏油烫伤他。但杰基说，情况并非如此，乔克·尼尔森当时穿着完整的衣服。
Was he making any kind of noise, as the tar went over him?
当柏油浇在他身上时，他有没有发出什么声音？
No. No. Not that I could hear from a distance.
没有。没有。至少我在远处没听到。
Right. OK. So he wasn't screaming or anything.
明白了。好。所以他没有尖叫什么的。
No, no. I think he was happy enough that that's all that was happening to him.
没有，没有。我想他对自己只遭遇了这些还感到庆幸呢。
But he must have some kind of-- it must have been terrible.
但他一定经历了一些……那一定很可怕。
Well, certainly, and it was meant to be. You have to remember, 10 years ago, this fellow would have been found, shot dead, [INAUDIBLE]. But because of the peace process and people moving on, things have been dealt with differently. And at the end of the day, tarring and feathering wasn't the worst thing could have happened. It could have been a lot worse.
嗯，当然，而且目的就是要让他感到可怕。你要记住，10年前，这家伙会被人发现枪杀在某处。但由于和平进程和人们向前看，事情的处理方式不同了。最终，柏油与羽毛惩罚并不是可能发生的最坏结果。情况可能糟得多。
Although the original story that we saw about this in the Daily Mail said that the guy who was tarred and feathered had been selling drugs to children, Jon came out of his visit to Belfast not sure that's true at all, or anyway, if it's the whole truth. A former BBC reporter named Brian Rowan, who's reported on Northern Ireland for over 20 years, pointed out to Jon that a guy like this one who was allegedly selling drugs might have been seen by the paramilitary groups as competition for their own drug operations.
尽管我们看到的《每日邮报》关于这件事的原始报道说那个被惩罚的人向孩子兜售毒品，但乔恩在贝尔法斯特采访后，并不确定那是事实，或者至少不确定那是全部真相。一位前BBC记者布莱恩·罗恩（Brian Rowan）在北爱尔兰报道了20多年，他向乔恩指出，像这个涉嫌卖毒品的人，可能被准军事组织视为他们自己毒品生意的竞争对手。
And while it is presented in this kind of Robin Hood fashion of defender of the community and helper of the community, these are paramilitary organizations who themselves are involved in drugs, are involved in crime. This is their way of presenting themselves in the light that they would like to present themselves in, that they're defenders of the community.
虽然这件事表现出一种罗宾汉式的、社区捍卫者或社区帮手的形象，但这些准军事组织本身就涉及毒品和犯罪。这就是他们展示自己的方式，他们想表现得像是社区的捍卫者。
Keep in mind, also, that the allegation that Jock Nelson sold drugs is coming only from the paramilitary groups, that he never got due process. He got no day in court. We did reach out to him, to Jock Nelson, the guy who got tarred and feathered to get his side of the story.
还要记住，乔克·尼尔森卖毒品的指控仅来自准军事组织，他从未得到正当程序。他没能上法庭辩护。我们确实联系了他，试图听听他的说法。
We tried. We contacted him on Twitter. And he just sent us a message saying he didn't want to talk to us. But good luck with our story.
我们试过了。我们在推特上联系了他。他只给我们回了一条消息，说他不想跟我们谈。但祝我们的报道好运。
How's he doing?
他现在怎么样了？
He's left Belfast for a while, went to Scotland. And now he's back working as a traffic warden.
他离开贝尔法斯特一段时间，去了苏格兰。现在他回来了，当了一名交通管理员。
A traffic warden gives out parking tickets.
交通管理员是开罚单的。
And I said to Jackie McDonald, is he back selling drugs? And Jackie McDonald said, look, if he was back selling drugs, he wouldn't be a traffic warden right now. He'd be dead.
我问杰基·麦克唐纳，他有没有重操旧业卖毒品？杰基说，看，如果他还在卖毒品，他现在就当不了交通管理员了。他早就死了。
You've been in prison yourself. So you know from both sides. What is the best deterrent? Is it going to prison or is it being tarred and feathered?
你自己也进过监狱，所以你了解双方的观点。什么才是最好的威慑？是进监狱，还是柏油与羽毛的惩罚？
Oh, tarred and feathering, without a doubt. I think, with ordinary decent criminals, [INAUDIBLE], drug dealers, thieves, hoods, whatever, there's something like 47%, 48%, 49% re-offend. With tarring and feathering, it's only had to happen once. There's been no re-offending since.
哦，毫无疑问是柏油与羽毛惩罚。我认为，对于普通罪犯、毒贩、小偷、恶棍之流，再犯率大概有47%、48%、49%。而用了柏油与羽毛的惩罚，只需要一次就够了。此后再也没有重犯。
Well, today on our radio show, "Tarred and Feathered." Apparently, humiliating somebody in public is something lots of people enjoy. And it's also really effective. It gets results. People leave town. People change.
好的，今天我们的电台节目主题是“柏油与羽毛”。显然，当众羞辱某人是很多人喜欢做的事情。而且它非常有效。它能带来结果。人们会离开城镇。人们会改变。
We have stories today of people who very much do not want public shaming. And they take action, dramatic action. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
我们今天有关于那些非常不希望被公众羞辱的人的故事。他们采取了行动，戏剧性的行动。来自WBEZ芝加哥，这是《美国生活》，由公共广播国际台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One. The Hounds of Blairsville. There are all kinds of ways that you could be tarred and feathered, but the effects are pretty much the same, I think. People stop talking to you. You're a pariah. Stephanie Foo has this story from a small town in Georgia called Blairsville.
第一幕：布莱尔斯维尔的猎犬。你可以通过各种方式遭遇柏油与羽毛的惩罚，但我认为效果大多是一样的。人们停止和你说话。你成了贱民。斯蒂芬妮·福（Stephanie Foo）带来了这个发生在佐治亚州布莱尔斯维尔小镇的故事。
Gene Cooley was planning his wedding. A second marriage for him and his fiancee Paulette. And one day he was at work cutting hair-- he's a hairstylist-- when he got a call from the police.
吉恩·库利（Gene Cooley）正在筹划他的婚礼。这是他和未婚妻宝莱特（Paulette）的第二次婚姻。一天，他在工作时给人剪头发——他是个发型师——这时他接到了警察的电话。
And starts asking me about a shooting, of course, I knew nothing about. And all of a sudden, then they mention about Paulette. And I just totally freaked out at that time. So, give me a minute?
警察开始问我关于一起枪击案的事，我当然一无所知。突然，他们提到了宝莱特。那一刻我彻底崩溃了。能给我一点时间吗？
Yeah, yeah, of course.
好的，当然可以。
Paulette's ex-husband had murdered Paulette and then killed himself. He'd been unhappy about her remarrying. She'd filed a restraining order against him. He'd been violent before. Police called it an open-and-shut case. Gene, of course, was completely wrecked. He flew to her parents' house for the funeral. Her family welcomed him into their home, cooked for him, comforted him. Until Gene's second day there, when Paulette's dad started acting strangely.
宝莱特的前夫谋杀了宝莱特，然后自杀了。他对她再婚很不满。她曾申请过限制令来防范他。他之前就有过暴力行为。警察把这定性为一起结案明确的谋杀自杀案。吉恩当然完全崩溃了。他飞到她父母家参加葬礼。她的家人欢迎他进家门，为他做饭，安慰他。直到吉恩在那里的第二天，宝莱特的父亲开始表现得很反常。
I'd kind of slept in a little bit or I stayed in the room a little bit. I think it was probably about 9:00. He made a comment about oh, you always sleep this late? And I said, no, sir. He was a little on the cold side. And we started to have a little bit of breakfast.
我当时睡得稍微多了一点，或者在房间里待久了点。我想可能大约是9点吧。他评论说，哦，你总是睡得这么晚吗？我说，没有，先生。他显得有点冷淡。我们开始吃早饭。
And he started asking me about rehab. And I said whose rehab? And he said your rehab. And I told him I've never been in a rehab. What are you talking about? And he said, well, what about drug addictions? And I said, I don't have a drug addiction. I don't know what you're talking about.
然后他开始问我关于康复中心的事。我说谁的康复中心？他说，你的康复中心。我告诉他，我从来没去过康复中心。你在说什么？他说，那么，关于毒瘾呢？我说，我没有毒瘾。我不知道你在说什么。
Of course, that's exactly what you'd say if you were a drug addict. So Paulette's dad didn't find that very persuasive.
当然，如果你是个瘾君子，你肯定会这么说。所以宝莱特的父亲觉得这话没多少说服力。
And that's when they informed me that they wanted me out.
就在那时，他们通知我，他们想让我离开。
Gene had no idea where this was coming from, and didn't know how to prove that he'd never been an addict. Finally, out of desperation, he offered to go to the police, ask them to run a background check, print it out, and bring it back to prove he had never been in trouble with the law for drugs. Paulette's father said, great. Here are directions. Go do it now.
吉恩完全不知道这事从哪儿冒出来的，也不知道怎么证明自己从来不是个瘾君子。最后，出于绝望，他提出去警察局，要求开一份背景调查，打印出来带回来，证明他从来没有因为毒品惹上过麻烦。宝莱特的父亲说，太好了。这是路线，现在就去办。
On the way, he called his sister in Blairsville to tell her Paulette's parents were acting really weird. And she said, something crazy is happening over here. Things are being said about you, bad things, all over the internet on something called Topix.
在路上，他给他在布莱尔斯维尔的姐姐打了电话，告诉她宝莱特的父母表现得非常奇怪。她说，这边发生了一些疯狂的事情。关于你的事情被传开了，坏事，整个互联网上都在传，在一个叫Topix的网站上。
Topix is a website. If you live in a big city, chances are you've never even heard of it. But if you live in a small town, you probably know exactly what I'm talking about. Topix was originally supposed to be a local news site. But in practice, it's just a big message board where anybody can create an account and post a news item. And so more often than not, in places like Blairsville, it's mostly gossip.
Topix是一个网站。如果你住在大城市，你可能根本没听说过它。但如果你住在小镇，你可能很清楚我在说什么。Topix最初被设想为一个本地新闻网站。但实际上，它就是一个巨大的留言板，任何人都可以注册账号并发布新闻。所以，在布莱尔斯维尔这样的地方，上面大多是流言蜚语。
Blairsville's roughly a mile square. It's got a population of about 650. And that day, dozens of people were commenting on Gene's fiancee's murder. At first, the comments were sympathetic, people saying they felt sorry for Paulette and her children. And then the comments got ugly.
布莱尔斯维尔大约有一平方英里大，人口约650人。那天，几十个人在评论吉恩未婚妻的谋杀案。起初，评论还很有同情心，人们说为宝莱特和她的孩子们感到难过。后来，评论变恶毒了。
There was like five or seven, I believe, user names being real hateful, real derogative, real just nasty on there. Calling me a pervert, making me out like I was a child molester, making me out like I was some kind of big drug user. You know, just total filth.
我想大概有五到七个用户名表现得非常憎恨，非常蔑视，非常恶心。叫我变态，把我描绘成猥亵儿童的人，把我描绘成某种大毒虫。你知道，全是脏水。
Someone with the user name Calvin asked, does anyone know the last name of Gene, the boyfriend hairstylist? I'm worried, because Gene is making his way down to Florida to meet with Paulette's side of the family. I'm truly fearful that this is not the end of this tragedy.
一个用户名叫“卡尔文”（Calvin）的人问，有人知道那个发型师男友吉恩的姓吗？我很担心，因为吉恩正要去佛罗里达见宝莱特那边的家人。我真的害怕这悲剧还没结束。
Someone named Mouth then said, keep that creep away from the children. He is trouble. What would you do if the perv was chasing your grandchildren? Calvin thanked Mouth for the warning.
一个叫“嘴巴”（Mouth）的人接着说，让那个变态离孩子远点。他是祸害。如果变态在追你的孙子，你会怎么办？卡尔文感谢“嘴巴”的警告。
And then someone who called himself Bugs added, Gene is not a nice guy. He cheated on his first wife. I know Paulette and Gene well, and they were both sickening out in public, kissing all over one another.
然后一个自称“臭虫”（Bugs）的人补充道，吉恩不是个好人。他背叛了他的第一任妻子。我认识宝莱特和吉恩，他们在公开场合那种亲吻腻歪的样子真让人作呕。
It continued on like this. People accused him of every kind of character flaw you could imagine, of getting fired from every job he had, of being a liar, a drunk.
评论就这样继续下去。人们指责他你能想象到的各种性格缺陷，说他丢了所有工作，是个骗子，是个酒鬼。
And I mean, to make accusations like that? I was wondering who the hell it was.
我的意思是，去做出那样的指控？我当时在想，这到底是谁干的。
Did you have any guesses?
你有什么猜测吗？
I had no idea who it could be. I've never been on a website like that. I don't really use a computer that much.
我完全不知道可能是谁。我从来没上过那种网站。我不怎么用电脑。
That's a huge understatement. Gene didn't know what YouTube was, until I explained it to him. It might not seem like a big deal that a couple of idiots are gossiping about you on the internet. But in a small town, it's different. You almost definitely know the people who wrote these things about you. And you know, the moment you walk outside your house, everyone you see has read it and is talking about it. Because in Blairsville, news travels fast.
这话太含蓄了。吉恩在跟我解释YouTube之前，甚至不知道那是什么。几个白痴在网上八卦你，这看起来可能没什么大不了。但在一个小镇，情况就不同了。你几乎肯定认识那些写这些话的人。而且你知道，当你走出家门的那一刻，你看到的每一个人都读过这些内容，并且在谈论它。因为在布莱尔斯维尔，消息传播得极快。
As a matter of fact, you being here for just a couple of hours before we met, I could almost tell you where you've been and what you even had for lunch.
事实上，你刚到这儿几个小时，我就几乎能说出你去过哪儿，甚至午饭吃的什么。
What do you mean? Like, just by asking other people?
你什么意思？就像通过问其他人吗？
You remember when you called me and said that you were about to have lunch? I'd already had two people call, and say, hey, did you know that there's a reporter over here in town?
你还记得当你给我打电话说你快要吃午饭的时候吗？我已经接到两个人的电话说，嘿，你知道镇上有个记者吗？
I didn't talk to anybody.
我没和任何人说话啊。
Maybe somebody who was eating at the restaurant?
也许是餐厅里吃饭的人？
That's a big possibility.
那很有可能。
When I walked into the restaurant Gene was talking about, I had noticed that everyone turned and gave me the side eye. The big guys in hunting gear in the back, the tiny neat woman in the front. I sat there awkwardly, wondering whether it was because I was the only Chinese person in town. When the waitress came up and asked me for my order, the restaurant went silent to hear what it was.
当我走进吉恩所说的那家餐厅时，我注意到每个人都转过头来，用斜眼打量我。后排那些穿着狩猎装备的大个子，前排那个瘦小的整洁女人。我尴尬地坐在那儿，纳闷是因为我是镇上唯一的华人吗。当服务员走过来问我要点什么时，整个餐厅都安静下来，想听听我会说什么。
And this sort of talk, it's mostly harmless. But when Topix came onto the scene, it took gossip between friends, gossip that people would ordinarily recognize as just gossip, and made it into something more serious.
这种谈话大多是无害的。但当Topix出现时，它把朋友间的八卦——人们通常会意识到这只是八卦——变成了一些更严重的东西。
This is Mark Cox. He's a friend of Gene's. He owns the hole-in-the-wall diner in town.
这是马克·考克斯（Mark Cox）。他是吉恩的朋友。他在镇上经营一家小餐馆。
You could tell somebody something and they'll kind of believe you. But if they see it in writing, they're going to believe it. Once you write it down, it's not gossip anymore. You know, that becomes truth for what people are concerned with.
你告诉某人一件事，他们会半信半疑。但如果他们看到写下来的文字，他们就会深信不疑。一旦写下来，它就不再是八卦了。你知道，对人们来说，那就成了真相。
Other people told me the same thing. Like this woman I met in town. She'd heard a friend gossiping about Gene, saying that he was a pervert, a child molester. She thought, yeah, right.
其他人也告诉我同样的事。比如我在镇上遇到的那位女士。她曾听到一个朋友八卦吉恩，说他是变态，是猥亵儿童的人。她当时想，得了吧。
I remember. I mean, I can remember back things being said and I just brush it off and  go on. But when it's written there, and for anybody, I mean, and if it's on the web, then you kind of like, oh my gosh, is this true? Could this happen, you know? It puts that seed of doubt in your head. Of course.
我记得。我的意思是，我记得以前说过的一些事，我只是置之不理。但当它被写在那里，对任何人来说，如果在网上，你就会想，天哪，这是真的吗？这可能发生吗？它会在你脑海中种下怀疑的种子。当然。
Gene did manage to calm his fiancee's parents down. But he was happy to go back home to Blairsville. He'd lived there for 16 years at that point, knew everybody. So when he got back, he was floored by the way people were suddenly treating him. Like, as if everything online was true.
吉恩确实设法让未婚妻的父母平静了下来。但他很高兴能回到布莱尔斯维尔的家中。那时他在那儿住了16年，认识所有人。所以当他回来时，人们突然对待他的方式让他大吃一惊。就好像网上说的一切都是真的。
OK, there was a gentleman that he and I used to pal around a little bit. Our children used to play together. I walked into a local convenience store and acknowledged him, told him hi. And he looked down at that point in time and just walked on out of the convenience store, got in his car and left.
好，有位先生，我和他以前经常混在一起。我们的孩子经常一起玩。我走进一家便利店向他打招呼，告诉他嗨。当时他低着头，直接走出了便利店，上了车就走了。
Or there was a guy he'd known for a while, who he ran into at a park.
还有个他认识很久的人，在公园里偶遇。
I just tried to have a little conversation with him. And he just told me pretty much get the F-word out of here. Get your perverted ass away from the kids. So I didn't know what to do at that point in time. I just left the-- I just had to go.
我只是试着跟他聊了两句。他却直接对我说，滚远点。带着你那变态的屁股滚离小孩远点。在那一刻我真不知道该怎么办。我只好离开——我只能走。
I mean, the feeling was atrocious. I felt like I was a ghost. When your friends aren't talking to you, when people aren't even looking at you, I mean, it's at your bottom's end, right there. I mean, you feel worse than the manure laying on the damn ground. Because people at least step in manure, but they want to walk around you like crazy.
我的意思是，那种感觉简直糟糕透顶。我觉得自己像个鬼魂。当你的朋友不跟你说话，当人们甚至看都不看你一眼，我的意思是，这简直是人生谷底。我觉得自己比地上的粪便还不如。因为人们至少会踩在粪便上，但他们却像躲避瘟神一样躲着我。
Gene tried to get back to work at his hair salon, but all his clients canceled their appointments. Here's Gene's boss, Tony Smelt.
吉恩试图回到发廊工作，但所有客人都取消了预约。这是吉恩的老板，托尼·斯梅尔特（Tony Smelt）。
There were rumors going around that Gene may have done some drugs in his past, and that we were supplying him, and that my wife and I were drug-dealing pagans. I don't know where the information came from. I mean, we just certainly don't do drugs, and we're not pagans. We eat organic food, so--
到处有流言说吉恩过去可能吸过毒，我们在供给他，我和我妻子是卖毒品的异教徒。我不知道这些信息是从哪儿来的。我的意思是，我们肯定不碰毒品，我们也不是异教徒。我们吃有机食品，所以……
Tony is obviously not a local. He's from England. And he was new to town at that point. His business had only been around a year, and he couldn't afford trouble. Tony said people had even called the salon, asking if Gene was there, and saying they wouldn't come in anymore if he was. One woman said she was afraid that Gene might shoot her. So Tony asked Gene not to come into work anymore.
托尼显然不是本地人。他来自英国。当时他刚到镇上。他的店才开了一年，他担不起麻烦。托尼说，甚至有人打电话到沙龙，问吉恩在不在，并说如果他在，他们就不来了。有一个女人说她担心吉恩可能会枪杀她。所以托尼请求吉恩以后不要再来上班了。
Topix is like a virus. People are scared of that website. I am, that's for sure.
Topix就像病毒。人们害怕那个网站。我肯定是的。
Gene couldn't find another job in town. 2 and 1/2 months after his fiancee's death, he decided he'd had enough. Gene packed up to move to Augusta, 3 and 1/2 hours away. But he made one last stop on the way out of town, the office of Russell Stookey.
吉恩在镇上找不到另一份工作。未婚妻死后两个半月，他决定受够了。吉恩打包准备搬去3个半小时车程外的奥古斯塔。但在离开城镇前，他最后去了一个地方，罗素·斯图基（Russell Stookey）的办公室。
Hi, Mr. Stookey.
嗨，斯图基先生。
Hi, are you Jennifer?
嗨，你是詹妮弗吗？
Stephanie.
是斯蒂芬妮。
Stephanie, I'm sorry.
斯蒂芬妮，抱歉。
Close enough.
差不多。
Come on. You're the first China lady I've ever met.
来吧。你是我见过的第一个中国女士。
China lady?
中国女士？
China lady.
中国女士。
OK.
好的。
Russell's a sweet guy. But he does say exactly what's on his mind, which actually made him the perfect man to take Gene's case, because when Russell heard Gene's story, he despised the whole idea of anonymous posters. And all he wanted to do is give them hell.
罗素是个可爱的人。但他说话直来直去，这反而使他成为受理吉恩案的最佳人选，因为当罗素听到吉恩的故事时，他鄙视匿名发帖的那套做法。他只想让他们付出代价。
They have no character. That means they have no guts. They have no guts, no character. They lack courage, no balls at all. (WHISPERED)  Should I say balls? Anyway, I'm old school. If I've got something to say, I'll say it to your damn face. [GUFFAWS] That's just the way it is. You see these scars on my face? A lot of times, people don't like that. And they'll punch you. But that's their opportunity. And that's the way you do business in this life. You say it to their face.
他们没有品格。这意味着他们没胆量。他们没胆量，没品格。他们缺乏勇气，一点骨气都没有。（低声）我该说“蛋蛋”吗？反正，我是老派人。如果我有话要说，我会当面告诉你。（大笑）事情就是这样。你看到我脸上的伤疤了吗？很多时候，人们不喜欢那样。他们会揍你。但这正是他们的机会。这就是这辈子做事的规矩。你要当面说出来。
The case was tricky. Topix isn't liable for what its users post. And they wouldn't tell Russell the true identities of the posters. It took a year and a half, but eventually a case in Texas went through. A federal judge ruled that Topix had to give up the true identities of any slanderous posters. So Russell used that ruling to find out who the anonymous posters really were. And what he found shocked him.
案子很棘手。Topix不对其用户的发布内容承担责任。他们不会告诉罗素这些发帖者的真实身份。这花了一年半的时间，最终德克萨斯州的一个案件取得了进展。一位联邦法官裁定，Topix必须交出任何诽谤性发帖者的真实身份。所以罗素利用那个裁决查出了这些匿名发帖者到底是谁。他发现的内容让他大吃一惊。
The nastiest posters were actually just one person. Calvin, Mouth, Bugs, who were all going back and forth on Topix, talking about Gene and thanking each other for their warnings about him-- they were all the same woman, a woman who had gone to the trouble of making multiple accounts and then having fake conversations between those accounts. Her name was Sybil Denise Ballew. And when Gene heard her name--
最恶毒的发帖者其实只有一个人。卡尔文、“嘴巴”、“臭虫”，这些在Topix上互相往来，谈论吉恩并互相感谢对方警告的人——她们全都是同一个女人，一个费尽心思创建多个账号，然后让这些账号之间虚假对话的女人。她的名字叫西比尔·丹妮丝·巴柳（Sybil Denise Ballew）。当吉恩听到她的名字时——
I had no idea who it was.
我完全不知道那是谁。
Gene was totally baffled. It wasn't until much later that he learned that over 10 years ago, he and Sybil Ballew had both worked at a department store in town called Alexander's. Most people in town call it the Hillbilly Walmart, though it's more like a general store. Gene says he only worked there for three months, mostly in the warehouse. He barely remembers it. But Sybil says she remembers him perfectly.
吉恩彻底困惑了。直到很久以后，他才知道，10多年前，他和西比尔·巴柳都在镇上一家叫亚历山大（Alexander's）的百货商店工作过。镇上大多数人把它叫“山里人的沃尔玛”，尽管它更像个杂货店。吉恩说他只在那儿工作了三个月，主要在仓库。他几乎不记得了。但西比尔说她对他记忆犹新。
I don't like the way he looked at the younger girls in staff where we worked together. Looking them up and down, lusty look. You know what I'm saying? There's a difference in looking, and there is a difference in (ELONGATING) "looooking."
我不喜欢他看我们一起工作的年轻女孩的方式。从上到下打量，那种淫荡的目光。你懂我的意思吗？“看”和“打……量”是有区别的。
Sybil talked to me on the phone. She refused to see me when I was in Blairsville. And to this day, she believes Gene had it coming.
西比尔在电话里跟我聊过。当我在布莱尔斯维尔时，她拒绝见我。直到今天，她依然认为吉恩是罪有应得。
He's the reason the woman's dead. He is the very reason that woman is dead. He knew how her (EMPHASIS) "husband" was. But yet, he kept doing what he was doing. He'd come in there with her on numerous times. Sit in the corner, and that woman couldn't even eat for him pawing at her, being gross. You know what I'm saying? You don't do stuff like that out in public, for God's sake. People went back and told the ex-husband to get the ex-husband riled up and disturbed enough about it to kill the woman.
那个女人死就是因为他。那个女人死完全是因为他。他知道她“丈夫”是什么样的人。但他还是继续做他做的事。他多次带她进那儿。坐在角落里，那女人因为他毛手毛脚、举止粗俗甚至连饭都吃不下。你知道我在说什么吗？看在上帝的份上，你不能在公共场合做那种事。人们回去告诉了前夫，把前夫激怒了，闹得动静大到让他杀了那女人。
What business is it of yours, though? I mean, it seems like you're making a lot of assumptions.
但这关你什么事呢？我的意思是，你好像做了很多假设。
Did you not understand or listen to what I said? He brought it upon himself in my opinion.
你没听懂或没听我说的话吗？在我看来，是他自找的。
Are you proud of what you did?
你为你所做的事感到自豪吗？
[SCOFFS] Am I proud of what I did? I'm proud of standing up for what I believe in, for what I know. I'm proud of telling the truth.
（嗤笑）我为你所做的事感到自豪吗？我为坚持我所相信的、所知道的事情感到自豪。我为说出真相感到自豪。
Gene sued Sybil Ballew for libel and defamation of character. Again, here's Gene's lawyer, Russell Stookey.
吉恩以诽谤和损害名誉的罪名起诉了西比尔·巴柳。再次提一下，这是吉恩的律师，罗素·斯图基。
So I had Mrs. Ballew on the stand. And to show what kind of legal scholar she is, I said-- she kept telling us about the First Amendment protected her. And I said, Ms. Ballew, you mentioned the First Amendment. Do you know what the First Amendment says? What is the first word in the First Amendment of the Constitution of the United States of America? She didn't know that. Here's a flash for you, morons. The First Amendment does not cover all speech. Defamation is not ever protected speech.
所以我在庭上质问了巴柳太太。为了显示她是个什么样的“法律学者”，我说——她一直在跟我们念叨第一修正案保护她。我说，巴柳女士，你提到了第一修正案。你知道第一修正案说了什么吗？美国宪法第一修正案的第一个词是什么？她不知道。给你们提个醒，白痴们。第一修正案并不涵盖所有言论。诽谤从来不是受保护的言论。
Russell's right. Libel is against the law. And if the lies hurt the victim financially, that person is entitled to receive payback. The jury ruled that Sybil Denise Ballew owed Gene $404,000, with $250,000 in punitive damages. It was the first successful lawsuit lodged against an anonymous Topix poster.
罗素是对的。诽谤是非法的。如果谎言在经济上伤害了受害者，当事人有权获得补偿。陪审团裁定，西比尔·丹妮丝·巴柳需赔偿吉恩40.4万美元，其中25万美元为惩罚性赔偿。这是针对匿名Topix发帖者的首个胜诉案例。
[EXHALES] God almighty. He went home that night, feeling like a man.
（呼气）天哪。他那天晚上回家时，感觉自己像个真正的男人。
It wasn't a complete triumph. The case was expensive, and Gene will probably never see any sort of reimbursement for that. To this day, Sybil has not paid any of the $404,000 to Gene. Russell says she just does not have that kind of money.
这不是一个彻底的胜利。诉讼费用昂贵，而且吉恩可能永远看不到任何赔偿。直到今天，西比尔还没付给吉恩那40.4万中的任何一分钱。罗素说她根本拿不出那么多钱。
But Gene got what was most important to him. He moved back to Blairsville after the case, back to his family, his friends, his kids. And, of course, everyone had heard about the verdict by the time he got back. And people started talking to him again like nothing had happened, like that guy in the convenience store, the guy who walked out when Gene tried to talk to him?
但吉恩得到了对他来说最重要的一切。案子结束后他搬回了布莱尔斯维尔，回到了家人、朋友、孩子身边。当然，他回来时，大家都听说了判决结果。人们又开始像什么都没发生一样和他说话了，比如那个在便利店的人，那个吉恩试图跟他说话时走开的家伙？
I saw him the other day at a convenience store. And he greeted me. Hi Gene, how are you doing? It's good seeing you. We shook hands, and I'll talk to you later. I'll see you around.
前几天我在便利店看到他。他跟我打招呼。嗨，吉恩，你好吗？见到你真好。我们握了手，我会再和你聊。回头见。
You must have some sort of feeling like, oh, now you want to talk to me?
你一定有种感觉，哦，现在你想跟我说话了？
Yes. [RUEFUL LAUGH] Yeah, that is kind of how I did feel, to be honest with you. I see everybody a lot differently now that I've been through all this. I just look at different people more cautious, instead of letting them into my life, letting them into my heart. I never thought that people could be so cruel.
是的。（自嘲地笑）说实话，我的感觉确实是那样。经历了这一切后，我看每个人都大不相同了。我只是更谨慎地看待不同的人，不再随意让他们进入我的生活、进入我的内心。我从没想过人们会如此残忍。
I asked around town to see if stories like Gene's were common. And almost everyone knew someone who'd been hurt by posts on Topix. One woman told me that someone wrote a post saying her coworker was having an affair. She said her co-worker's marriage fell apart because of it. And her kids were teased at school. Another said her husband was slandered, which hurt the family business.
我在镇上打听了一下，看看吉恩这样的故事是否常见。几乎每个人都认识受Topix帖子伤害的人。一位女士告诉我，有人写帖子说她的同事在搞外遇。她说她同事的婚姻因此破裂了。她的孩子在学校也受到嘲弄。另一位说她的丈夫被诽谤了，这伤害了家族生意。
But after Gene's case, after people found out they could sue for slander, lots of people started to call up lawyers. Russell Stookey says he probably gets a call every month.
但在吉恩案之后，在人们发现可以起诉诽谤后，很多人开始打电话找律师。罗素·斯图基说他每个月大概能接到一个电话。
Normally, you're talking about bored housewives who are just gossip-mongers, basically. But it is an epidemic. I have caught lawyers. I caught a judge. I've caught doctors, a dentist, a state representative. I found out in a heartbeat who these people were. I sued them. And you ought to hear them scream and cry. Let me go. Let me out of this. You did it.
通常，这都是些无聊的家庭主妇，说白了就是八卦传播者。但这已经是一种流行病了。我抓住过律师。我抓住过法官。我抓住过医生、牙医、州议员。我瞬间就查到了这些人是谁。我起诉了他们。你应该听听他们尖叫、哭喊的样子。放过我吧。让我从这事里解脱吧。你们做得太绝了。
If you go on to Blairsville's Topix page today, there are only a dozen or so regular posters left. It's considered an embarrassment now. And nobody really reads the gossip anymore. Or anyway, if they do, nobody wants to admit it.
如果你今天登录布莱尔斯维尔的Topix页面，只剩下十几条常规帖子了。这现在被视为一种尴尬。也没人真正再去看那些八卦了。或者说，即使看，也没人愿意承认。
Stephanie Foo is one of the producers of our program. Coming up, we move from a story where the internet is causing huge problems in somebody's life to a story where the internet is actually helping somebody solve a huge problem. That's in a minute. From Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
斯蒂芬妮·福是我们节目的制作人之一。接下来，我们将从一个互联网给某人生活带来巨大麻烦的故事，过渡到一个互联网确实帮助某人解决巨大麻烦的故事。一分钟后回来。来自芝加哥公共广播和公共广播国际台，节目继续。
We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, Help Wanted. So this story is about a group that's pretty universally reviled. I think if there ever was a group that people would want to tar and feather, this would be the group. And that's pedophiles. Though I have to say, before we start, this is not the story you usually hear about pedophiles.
我们进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，招聘启事。这个故事是关于一个普遍被唾弃的群体。我想如果这世上真有什么群体是人们想用“柏油与羽毛”惩罚的，那一定就是这个群体。那就是恋童癖者。不过我必须在开始之前说，这不是你通常听到的那种关于恋童癖者的故事。
Reporter Luke Malone met somebody who has those feelings for young children and definitely does not want to act on them, and has to cobble together his own way to deal with the problem which raises the question is there a way to treat pedophiles. Could there be a way to treat pedophiles?
记者卢克·马龙（Luke Malone）见到一个人，他对幼童有这种感觉，但绝对不想付诸行动，而且必须想尽办法自己去处理这个问题，这提出了一个问题：有没有办法治疗恋童癖者？是否存在治疗恋童癖者的方法？
A warning, before we start, this story is definitely not for kids. Most of the names have been changed and two of the people in this story have asked to have their voices altered. Also, though there's nothing graphic in this story at all, victims of child sexual abuse should consider this a trigger warning.
开始前有个警告，这个故事绝对不适合儿童收听。大多数名字都经过了修改，故事中的两个人要求将他们的声音进行处理。此外，虽然这个故事中没有任何露骨的内容，但儿童性虐待的受害者应将此视为一个触发预警。
Everybody else, I will say, I have never heard anybody talk about these issues the way that the people in this story talk about them. I feel like I came out of hearing this story understanding something I really did not know before. So here's Luke Malone.
至于其他人，我会说，我从未听过有人像这个故事中的人们那样讨论这些问题。我觉得听完这个故事，我理解了一些以前确实不知道的东西。下面请听卢克·马龙的报道。
My interest in pedophiles began in the wake of the Jerry Sandusky trial. He had just been sentenced on 45 counts related to child sex abuse. It got me thinking about how all this starts and if there's a way to prevent it. I mean, Sandusky wasn't born a 68-year-old child molester. How old are pedophiles when they start thinking about kids this way? Do they ever want to do something to stop themselves? And if they do, who can they turn to?
我对恋童癖者的兴趣始于杰瑞·桑达斯基（Jerry Sandusky）庭审之后。他刚刚因为与儿童性虐待相关的45项指控被判刑。这让我思考这一切是如何开始的，以及是否有办法预防。我的意思是，桑达斯基不是一出生就是68岁的猥亵儿童者。恋童癖者在什么年龄开始以这种方式看待孩子？他们是否有过阻止自己的念头？如果有，他们能向谁求助？
I spoke to experts and dug around online. I came across a site, a group of people who acknowledged their attraction, but want help dealing with it. Most of the men I spoke with first noticed an interest in children when they were about 13 or 14. I had no idea. I asked how they reacted when they first knew something was up.
我采访了专家并上网搜索。我偶然发现了一个网站，一群承认自己有这种吸引力，但想要寻求帮助来处理它的人。我采访的大多数男性在13或14岁左右时第一次注意到对儿童的兴趣。我完全没想到。我问他们第一次察觉到不对劲时有什么反应。
For most of them, this was going back 40 or 50 years. And I realized that I needed to speak with younger guys, ones who were going through this right now. I asked the men if they knew anyone like that. And a week or so later, I got an email.
对他们大多数人来说，那是40或50年前的事了。我意识到我需要采访一些年轻人，那些现在正经历这些的人。我问那些男士是否认识这样的人。一周左右后，我收到了一封电子邮件。
My name is Adam, it read. I'm 18, and I'm the leader of a support group for pedophiles around my age. I'll be very happy to talk with you. Adam is now 19. Just to remind you, Adam isn't his real name. And his voice has been altered to protect his identity. But even knowing he'd be anonymous, he was uncomfortable.
“我叫亚当，”信中写道，“我18岁，是一个同龄恋童癖互助小组的负责人。我很乐意和你谈谈。”亚当现在19岁。提醒一下，亚当不是他的真名。他的声音经过处理以保护身份。但即使知道会匿名，他还是很不安。
You know, nervous.
你知道，很紧张。
Why?
为什么？
Just don't think I'm a very vulgar person. It's even weird for me to say it out loud. You know, it's something I type, probably 50 times a day, just chatting with some people online, but actually saying it out loud is not very easy for me.
就是不觉得我是个很粗俗的人。连大声说出来对我来说都很奇怪。你知道，这只是我打字会用的东西，可能每天聊天时会打50次，但实际上大声说出来对我来说并不容易。
Do you see yourself as a pedophile?
你把自己看作恋童癖者吗？
Uh, yes.
嗯，是的。
And have you ever acted on your attraction?
你有没有根据你的吸引力采取过行动？
No.
没有。
Here's the first of many distinctions, I wasn't clear on when I first met Adam. And it's an important one to make. Technically, you don't have to act on your desires to be a pedophile. Pedophilia marks the attraction, not the behavior. Adam doesn't want to act on his attractions.
这是我第一次见到亚当时不清楚的众多区别之一。这是一个很重要的区别。从技术上讲，你不必根据你的欲望去行动就能成为恋童癖者。恋童癖标志的是一种吸引力，而不是行为。亚当不想采取行动。
Adam is self-diagnosed, as is everyone in his online support group. They go by the medical definition of pedophilia found in the DSM, the Diagnostic and Statistical Manual of Mental Disorders, basically the Bible of the American Psychiatric Association, which says that in order to be a pedophile, you have to harbor sexual fantasies about or engage sexually with a prepubescent child for six months or more, and you have to be 16 or above and more than five years older than the child. You also need to have either acted on these urges, or the fantasies must cause distress or difficulty.
亚当是自我诊断的，他在网上的互助小组成员也是。他们遵循DSM（《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》）中关于恋童癖的医学定义，这基本上是美国精神医学协会的圣经。书中指出，要成为恋童癖者，你必须在六个月或更长时间内对青春期前的儿童抱有性幻想或发生性行为，且年龄在16岁以上，并比该儿童年长五岁以上。你还需要要么已经付诸行动，要么这些幻想必须引起痛苦或困难。
Guys like Adam hit puberty and discover they're attracted to little kids. And what's remarkable is that they have to navigate that all on their own, with no frame of reference. Everything they're going through, they have to figure out for themselves at, like, 11. I was surprised when Adam first told me the specifics of his attraction. It was hard to relate to, and so you're prepared, difficult to hear.
像亚当这样的人进入青春期，发现自己被幼童吸引。最了不起的是，他们必须完全依靠自己去摸索，没有任何参考框架。他们经历的一切，在11岁左右时就得自己去搞定。当亚当第一次告诉我他这种吸引力的细节时，我很惊讶。这很难产生共鸣，而且为了让你做好准备，这听起来也很艰难。
He's most attracted to kids between the ages of eight and three. He was 14 when he started watching porn, porn involving children. For privacy, he found a way to connect an old computer that he had in his room. Before long, he was downloading it on a daily basis. He couldn't believe how easy it was.
他最受8到3岁之间的孩子吸引。他14岁时开始看色情片，涉及儿童的色情片。为了隐私，他想办法把房间里的一台旧电脑连上网。没过多久，他每天都在下载。他不敢相信这有多容易。
It was exhilarating. That's the most accurate thing I could say about it.
那很令人振奋。这是我能说的最准确的话。
I think for people who are listening to this show, when they hear that, it's going to be kind of hard for them to understand what you're feeling. And I really want them to. So can you tell me, did you have any concerns for the kid in the videos at this time? Did it occur that someone else was abusing them by making these videos?
我想对于听这节目的听众来说，当他们听到这话时，会很难理解你的感受。我真的很希望他们能懂。所以你能告诉我，当时你有没有为视频里的孩子担心过？有没有想到过别人通过制作这些视频正在虐待他们？
No. First off, the first child pornography I came across I don't think it even involved adults. What I thought as, I'd like to do these types of things. So it's great that I can watch other people who are closer to my age range do these types of things. I just see two kids doing something that I fantasized about doing. So, you know, I'm one of the kids.
没有。首先，我接触到的第一部儿童色情片甚至不涉及成年人。我的想法是，我想做这些事。所以能看到和我年龄段相近的人做这些事真是太好了。我只是看到两个孩子在做我幻想中会做的事。所以，你知道，我就是其中一个孩子。
Remember, he was 14.
记住，他当时才14岁。
And it was a little while later, as I started watching this stuff more and more, when I kind of realized that I was getting older, and it wasn't some phase I was going through, but the children I was interested in weren't getting older, you know, to follow along with me, but they were actually getting younger.
过了一会儿，随着我越来越频繁地看这些东西，我意识到自己正在变老，这并不是什么我经历的阶段，但我感兴趣的孩子们并没有变老，你知道，没有跟我一起成长，他们实际上变得更小了。
Did it strike you as wrong?
这让你觉得不对劲吗？
At that age, no. I knew it was illegal. I knew it was considered wrong. But I did not know why it was considered wrong. I figured it was something that wasn't allowed. I'd been using it for two years, before I started to think these children are real people. And they could potentially be hurt with this.
那个年龄不会。我知道这是非法的。我知道这被认为是错的。但我不知道为什么这被认为是错的。我想这只是不被允许的事情。我看了两年，才开始想到这些孩子是真实的人。他们可能会因为这个而受到伤害。
The way Adam figured it out was particularly brutal. He was 16, and he came across a video he wanted to unsee. There's no easy way to say this. It involved a very small child. An 18-month-old.
亚当发现这一点的方式特别残酷。他16岁时，偶然看到了一段他不想再看一次的视频。没有简单的方法来表达这一点。它涉及到一个非常小的孩子，一个18个月大的孩子。
I remember thinking that I wanted to reach through the computer screen and kill the person. I was just so horrified at what I saw. At that point, I knew something was really wrong.
我记得当时我想伸手穿过电脑屏幕杀了那个人。看到这一切我真是太恐惧了。那一刻，我知道确实有什么不对劲了。
He began reading up on child abuse and was upset at what he learned. He decided he wanted to stop watching child porn, and he needed help if he was going to do that. For that help, Adam turned back to the internet. He posted on a mental health forum, explaining his situation and asking for advice. Two women who were child abuse survivors befriended him. With their help, Adam says he stopped watching porn. But in its place grew a deep depression.
他开始阅读关于虐待儿童的内容，对学到的东西感到难过。他决定他想停止看儿童色情片，如果他想做到这一点，他需要帮助。为了得到这种帮助，亚当又转向了互联网。他在一个心理健康论坛上发帖，解释了他的处境并请求建议。两位儿童性虐待幸存的女性与他结为朋友。在她们的帮助下，亚当说他停止了看色情片。但在它取而代之的是深深的抑郁。
It wasn't like he'd stopped having sexual thoughts about kids. He says he felt like a monster for having viewed the videos, but also just for having the attractions. Some days, he thought about killing himself. He didn't know what else to do. He was 16. He wanted to talk to someone. So he started with a cautious letter to his mum.
这并不是说他停止了对孩子的性幻想。他说他因为看过那些视频觉得自己是个怪物，但也因为有这种吸引力而感到羞愧。有些日子，他想自杀。他不知道还能做什么。他才16岁。他想找个人谈谈。于是他写了一封谨慎的信给妈妈。
Dear Mummy, it begins, I'm writing this letter to you, as I cannot bring myself to say what I need to say to you to your face. It would simply be too painful for me. I am always overshadowed with feelings of depression, guilt, and shame. I'm really sick and tired of covering these feelings up. I want you to let me see a psychologist. I understand you probably have a lot to ask me. But I need some time to get my head wrapped around things. Love, Adam.
“亲爱的妈妈，”信中开头写道，“我给你写这封信，因为我无法面对面跟你说我需要说的话。那对我来说太痛苦了。我总是笼罩在抑郁、内疚和羞耻的感觉中。我真的厌倦了掩盖这些感觉。我想让你让我去看心理医生。我知道你可能有话要问我。但我需要一点时间来想明白这些事。爱你的，亚当。”
He didn't explain the source of the problem, and his mother never asked. Instead, she made him an appointment at a local therapist for a week or so later.
他没解释问题的根源，他的母亲也没问。相反，她在接下来的一周左右给他预约了一位当地的治疗师。
I remember it was a Friday morning, very early in the day. I was her first patient. We got there, even before she got there. And I was just very nervous. I knew exactly what was coming. I'd known for so long that I was going to walk in there and what I was going to say. And I'd rehearsed it in my head.
我记得那是个周五早晨，很早。我是她的第一位病人。我们到了那儿，甚至比她到得还早。我当时非常紧张。我知道接下来会发生什么。我很早就知道我要走进那儿，我知道我要说什么。我在脑子里排练过。
And what was the script you'd been playing over and over in your head?
你脑子里反复播放的那套剧本是什么？
I'm a pedophile, and I'm addicted to child pornography. And I remember I walked in there, and we started talking. And then she kind of said, so what are you here for? And I said, well, I'm very anxious. And she said, well, why are you anxious? And my heart was beating. I'd never been so terrified in my life.
“我是个恋童癖者，我对儿童色情片上瘾。”我记得走进那儿，我们开始交谈。然后她问：“那么，你来这里是为了什么？”我说：“嗯，我非常焦虑。”她说：“嗯，你为什么焦虑？”我的心脏在跳动。我这辈子从没这么害怕过。
But I uttered the words. I said, well, this is difficult to say, but I'm a pedophile, and I'm addicted to child pornography. And I saw kind of a look of horror on her face, and she asked me to repeat that. She must have thought that she misheard me for something like that. But I repeated it. Then, immediately, she went from being this very nice, gentle person to very harsh and critical.
但我吐出了那几个字。我说：“嗯，这很难说出口，但我是个恋童癖者，我对儿童色情片上瘾。”我看到她脸上闪过一丝恐惧，她让我重复一遍。她肯定以为自己听错了。但我重复了一遍。然后，她立刻从那个非常友好、温柔的人变得非常严厉和尖锐。
What did she say to you?
她对你说了什么？
Well, she raised her voice, telling me this isn't OK. And we talked about it a bit. I mentioned that at that point, I'd been, I think, 11 weeks clean of child pornography. But I was terrified the whole time. And I remember she tried talking with me about why I have these attractions.
嗯，她提高了声音，告诉我这不可以。我们谈了一点。我提到在那一点上，我想我已经有11周没看儿童色情片了。但我全程都吓坏了。我记得她试图和我谈谈为什么我有这些吸引力。
And she was obviously convinced that I had trouble talking with people my own age, so I felt less judged by younger kids, and that's why I was interested in them. And that's apparently a very common thing for therapists who aren't at all trained in this area to think.
她显然认定我有跟同龄人交流的困难，所以我感觉不到被小孩子评判，这就是为什么我对他们感兴趣。对于那些在这个领域完全没受过训练的治疗师来说，这显然是一个非常普遍的想法。
So she didn't even believe that you were a pedophile. Just that you couldn't kind of make it with kids your own age, essentially, yeah? Is that what you're saying?
所以她甚至不相信你是恋童癖者。只是你无法跟同龄孩子相处，基本上是这样，是吗？你是想说这个吗？
Yes, yes.
是的，是的。
And what did you say to her in response?
那你回应了她什么？
Oh, well, I disagreed. I said, no, I really firmly believe that's not the case. I know what I'm attracted to. And it's not like I'm-- I had friends. It's not like I didn't have a single friend. I said, look, these attractions are more intense than they are towards any adult I've ever met or seen. And I'm really confident that it's not just being scared to talk to people my own age.
哦，嗯，我不同意。我说：“不，我坚定地相信情况并非如此。我知道我被什么吸引。这也不是说我——我有朋友。并不是说我没一个朋友。”我说：“看，这些吸引力比我对任何我见过或看到的成年人都要强烈。而且我真的很自信，这不仅仅是害怕和同龄人谈话。”
Was it kind of weird or frustrating kind of disclosing this massive thing about yourself and then having to kind of just really drive it on home and prove it to her?
披露关于自己的这件大事，然后还得费力去证明给她看，这感觉是不是有点奇怪或挫败？
Yeah, it was definitely-- it was annoying. But I'll tell you the feeling that overcame me most the whole time was that I was being judged. That's definitely what I felt most when I left later. I considered writing an email to her, apologizing for dropping such a bombshell on her. And I saw her again.
是的，这绝对是——很恼火。但我得告诉你，全程萦绕我的感觉是，我受到了审判。那绝对是我后来离开时感受最深的东西。我考虑过给她写封邮件，为向她投下这枚重磅炸弹表示道歉。然后我又见了一次她。
And what happened in that second session?
那第二次咨询发生了什么？
So she was a little calmer. She'd obviously had some time to think about it. She basically told me, pretty much instantly, that she couldn't help me. And she said that she'd looked around, but she couldn't really find much.
她冷静了一些。她显然有一些时间思考了。她基本上立刻告诉我说，她无法帮助我。她说她四处打听了一下，但确实没找到多少东西。
And then within a few minutes, she asks, how I'd feel if she told my mother about what was going on. So first, my heart obviously started beating much faster, and I became incredibly anxious. And I said, I really don't want to do that. So she left the room for a minute, and then came back in with my mother.
然后几分钟之内，她问我，如果她把我发生的事情告诉我妈妈，我会怎么想。所以首先，我的心脏明显跳得更快了，我变得非常焦虑。我说：“我真的不想那样做。”于是她离开了房间一分钟，然后带着我妈妈回来了。
And I sat down. And the first thing that I recall the therapist saying is we've got a problem.
我坐下。我记得治疗师说的第一句话是：“我们有麻烦了。”
This is Adam's mum. Her voice has also been altered.
这是亚当的妈妈。她的声音也经过了处理。
The therapist looked at me, and I can't remember her exact words, but it was something like--
治疗师看着我，我不记得她的原话了，但大概是这样——
Adam is addicted to pornography. And then she paused for a little bit, and then she said, a very specific type of pornography. Then she said it's child pornography.
“亚当对色情片上瘾。”然后她停顿了一下，接着说，“一种非常特殊的色情片。”然后她说那是儿童色情片。
And she continued to say that she couldn't see him. We then talked a little bit, not details, about what had been going on. And Adam did not contribute at all. He sat there just shaking and looking at the floor. And I do remember that she then turned to Adam and said, how do you feel? And he said, I feel like I'm going to throw up.
她接着说她没法辅导他了。我们谈了一会儿，没谈细节，谈了关于发生了什么。亚当全程没参与。他坐在那儿一直发抖，盯着地板。我还记得她转向亚当说：“你感觉怎么样？”他说：“我觉得我想吐。”
You know, my mother, I'm sure, reacted the best I really could have hoped for. She kind of put her arm on my shoulder and squeezed a little bit. She seemed to be supportive. I'm sure she was in shock, probably kind of horrified, but at least she was able to hide that. And the fact that she was able to do that, it meant so much to me.
你知道，我妈妈，我敢肯定，给出了我能希望到的最好反应。她把手搭在我的肩膀上，轻轻捏了捏。她看起来很支持我。我敢肯定她在震惊中，可能有点恐惧，但至少她能隐藏起来。她能这样做，这对我意义重大。
And I looked at him, although he wouldn't give me eye contact. I looked at him, and I said, Adam, we're going to help with this. Whatever it is, we can help with it. And don't worry, I'm with you.
我看着他，虽然他没和我进行眼神接触。我看着他说：“亚当，我们会解决这个的。不管是什么，我们都能解决。别担心，我和你在一起。”
On the car ride home, Adam told her that he wasn't just attracted to children, but also to adults.
在回家的车上，亚当告诉她，他不仅被儿童吸引，也被成年人吸引。
You know, and I explained that I'd never done anything to hurt someone before and that I never would do something to hurt someone.
你知道，我解释说我从未做过任何伤害别人的事，而且我永远也不会做伤害别人的事。
When I had moments to be alone afterwards, I was very devastated in realizing the enormity of what we were dealing with. I was shocked. It was the last thing that I could have fathomed that was a problem for him. There were absolutely no signs. I have no earthly idea how Adam may have developed his attraction to children.
此后我有机会独处时，意识到我们要处理的问题之严重性，我感到非常崩溃。我很震惊。这是我能想象到的他最不可能出现的问题。完全没有迹象。我一点儿也不知道亚当是怎么发展出对儿童的这种吸引力的。
She and Adam both say he wasn't abused. His home life was stable. He had good relationships with his siblings. Adam's mum did find him a new therapist, one who specialized in porn addiction. This one didn't normally treat minors, and he was reluctant to take Adam on. She had to plead with him to accept her son as a client. He eventually agreed.
她和亚当都说他没受过虐待。他的家庭生活稳定。他和兄弟姐妹关系良好。亚当的妈妈确实为他找了一位新治疗师，一位专门从事色情上瘾治疗的专家。这位专家通常不辅导未成年人，而且很不情愿接收亚当。她不得不恳求他接收自己的儿子作为客户。他最终同意了。
She says until our interview, his two therapists are the only people she's spoken to about Adam's attractions. She hasn't told a friend, not a therapist of her own, not her husband.
她说直到我们的这次采访，他的两位治疗师是她谈论过亚当吸引力问题的仅有的人。她没告诉朋友，没告诉自己的心理医生，没告诉丈夫。
Right now, if a pedophile shows up in a therapist's office wanting treatment, it puts a therapist in a difficult situation. First, there are no guidelines on how to treat pedophiles who haven't offended. There's a lot of confusion in the field about how to handle them. Also, they're in a tough legal position.
目前，如果一个恋童癖者出现在治疗师办公室寻求治疗，这会让治疗师陷入困境。首先，对于如何治疗未婚的恋童癖者没有指导方针。领域内对于如何处理他们存在很多混乱。此外，他们处于艰难的法律境地。
If a therapist thinks someone poses a threat to a child, they're legally obligated to turn them in, because of mandatory reporting laws. They can lose their license if they don't. So when it comes to counseling a pedophile, therapists have to gauge how likely that person is to act. They're in a sticky situation where they have to make a judgment call about how dangerous someone is.
如果治疗师认为某人对孩子构成威胁，根据强制报告法，他们有法律义务将其举报。如果不这么做，他们可能会失去执照。所以当谈到辅导恋童癖者时，治疗师必须衡量那个人采取行动的可能性有多大。他们处于一个棘手的境地，必须就某人有多危险做出判断。
Professor Elizabeth Letourneau is one of the top researchers on child sexual abuse in the world. She's done this work for 25 years. She says the great thing about mandatory reporting laws are that they've brought to light lots of crimes against children. But as they got more popular, she saw it affect the number of people reaching out for help.
伊丽莎白·勒图诺（Elizabeth Letourneau）教授是世界上研究儿童性虐待的顶级研究员之一。她从事这项工作25年了。她说，强制报告法的伟大之处在于它们揭露了许多针对儿童的罪行。但随着它们变得越来越普遍，她发现这影响了寻求帮助的人数。
Self-referrals for help really dried up. And people watched helplines just go silent, because folks are too afraid to reach out for help. The consequences are too high.
主动寻求帮助的人数真的干涸了。人们眼睁睁看着求助热线陷入沉默，因为人们太害怕寻求帮助了。后果太严重了。
Professor Letourneau is the director of the Moore Center for the Prevention of Child Sexual Abuse at Johns Hopkins University. And it's with that mandate, the prevention of child sexual abuse, that she's pushing hard for research into people like Adam. Amazingly, there's very little research on pedophilia. We don't know much about the sexuality of adolescents, let alone what might make someone a pedophile.
勒图诺教授是约翰霍普金斯大学儿童性虐待预防中心的主任。正是在预防儿童性虐待这一使命的驱使下，她正在大力推动对亚当这类人群的研究。令人惊讶的是，关于恋童癖的研究非常少。我们对青少年的性行为知之甚少，更不用说是什么可能使一个人成为恋童癖者了。
It is a gigantic black hole in science.
这是科学中的一个巨大的黑洞。
Among things we don't know, we don't know that there's a connection between being abused and developing an attraction to kids. Crazy, right? We don't know what's normal, when it comes to the sexual development of children. It might be normal for a 12 year old to be attracted to a six or eight year old.
我们不知道的事情中，包括不知道被虐待和产生对孩子的吸引力之间是否有联系。很疯狂，对吧？当涉及儿童性发育时，我们不知道什么是正常的。12岁的孩子被6或8岁的孩子吸引可能是正常的。
Another thing that has not been researched in-depth is if having an attraction to kids makes it more dangerous to be around them. On its face, it seems obvious. But there is no evidence to support it.
另一件没有经过深入研究的事情是，是否有对孩子的吸引力会使接近他们变得更危险。从表面上看，这似乎很明显。但没有任何证据支持这一点。
The research that we do have, and this is from a very small sample size, suggests that pedophiles are more lucky to be shorter, left-handed, and have a lower IQ. Another study says that being knocked unconscious before the age of 13 may be a factor. It shows just how little we've scratched the surface.
我们确实拥有的一些研究（基于很小的样本量）表明，恋童癖者更有可能是个子较矮、左撇子且智商较低。另一项研究称，在13岁之前因撞击失去知觉可能是一个因素。这显示了我们对真相的了解有多浅。
For years, Letourneau has been trying to change all this, to get money for research, and for prevention programs. But there's not much money for that. Funders don't want to be associated with pedophilia research. The stigma is too great. Even someone like Letourneau, who wants to do this research in order to prevent children from being abused, has been called a pedophile sympathizer, simply for advocating these programs.
多年来，勒图诺一直试图改变这一切，试图为研究和预防项目争取资金。但对此投入的资金并不多。资助者不想与恋童癖研究扯上关系。这种耻辱感太强烈了。甚至像勒图诺这样为了防止儿童被虐待而想要进行研究的人，仅仅因为倡导这些项目就被称为“恋童癖同情者”。
If we can prevent this, we can prevent a lot of harm and a lot of cost. And we just don't. It's nuanced. It's difficult to wrap your head around. It's a lot easier to say these guys are monsters. Let's put them in prison. Let's put them on a registry. Let's put them in civil commitment facilities. And forget about them.
如果我们能预防这一点，我们就能防止许多伤害和许多代价。但我们只是不做。这是微妙的。很难理解。说这些人是怪物要容易得多。把他们关进监狱。把他们放进登记处。把他们关进民事收容设施。然后忘掉他们。
The place that research is most solid is the numbers. Studies suggest that an astonishingly large number of men are pedophiles. A respected survey by Michael Seto, director of the Forensic Research Unit at the University of Ottawa, found that 3% of all men have sexually offended against a prepubescent child. Though not all these men would be considered pedophiles.
研究最坚实的地方是数字。研究表明，数量惊人多的男性是恋童癖者。渥太华大学法医研究部门主任迈克尔·塞托（Michael Seto）的一项权威调查发现，3%的男性曾经对青春期前的儿童进行过性侵犯。尽管并非所有这些男性都会被视为恋童癖者。
But he goes on to estimate that 1% to 3% of men would meet the diagnostic criteria for pedophilia, which equates to anywhere between 1.2 million and 3.4 million pedophiles in the US alone. That means there are lots of people out there who presumably try not to offend, with nowhere to turn to for help. There's almost no research to explain why they are the way they are, and no known treatment. Which is how a teenager might conclude that his best option is to invent his own way forward.
但他进而估计，1%到3%的男性符合恋童癖的诊断标准，这相当于仅在美国就有120万到340万恋童癖者。这意味着外面有很多人大概正努力不进行侵害，但却无处求助。几乎没有研究来解释他们为什么会这样，也没有已知的治疗方法。这就是为什么一个青少年可能会断定他最好的选择是自己想出一条路。
At 17, Adam started searching online for other guys like himself, young men struggling to deal with their attraction to kids. And some responded. They got to talking online. And soon there were a bunch of them, communicating on a daily basis. Before long, Adam realized that he had inadvertently formed a support group for young pedophiles.
17岁时，亚当开始在网上寻找像他一样的其他年轻人，那些正在努力应对被孩子吸引的年轻人。有些人回应了。他们在网上交谈。很快就有了不少人，每天都在沟通。没过多久，亚当意识到他无意中形成了一个针对年轻恋童癖者的互助小组。
There are currently nine members, ranging in age from 16 to 22, eight men and one woman. They communicate in the same way that any bunch of teenagers do-- Gchat, text, email, the odd phone call, or video chat. And there's usually at least a few people online each night. I've talked to five of them, and met three of those in person. They all said they're glad to have found the group. And for most, it's the only outlet they have. Everyone I've spoken to has a story about how the group saved them. A 22-year-old college student told me this one.
目前有9名成员，年龄从16岁到22岁不等，8男1女。他们以任何青少年都会用的方式沟通——Gchat、短信、电子邮件、偶尔的电话或视频聊天。通常每晚至少有几个人在线。我跟其中5个人聊过，亲自见过其中3个。他们都说很高兴找到了这个小组。对大多数人来说，这是他们唯一的出口。我采访过的每个人都有故事讲述这个小组如何拯救了他们。一名22岁的大学生告诉我这个故事。
There was a time when I was really running out of hope for the future. I was unemployed, and I felt like no one was going to give me a shot. And I felt like I had literally no shot in life. And I kind of wanted to kill myself. I didn't do it. The first thing I thought of was especially Adam, in specific, but the rest of them as well, that I couldn't let them down like that.
有段时间我真的对未来快要失去希望了。我失业了，我觉得没人会给我一个机会。我觉得我在生活中真的毫无希望。我甚至想自杀。我没做。我首先想到的是亚当，具体说就是他，当然还有其他成员，我不能那样辜负他们。
The governing principle of the group is that you can only be a part of it if you agree that it's wrong to have sex with kids. There are other pedophile support groups online who feel the opposite, who advocate for the abolishment of age of consent laws. Others suggest that molesting children is wrong because it's illegal, but stop short of taking a moral stand.
小组的准则是，只有当你同意与孩子发生性关系是错误的时候，你才能成为其中的一员。网上还有其他的恋童癖互助小组持相反意见，他们主张废除同意年龄法。其他人则认为猥亵儿童是错的，因为这是非法的，但止步于此，没有采取道德立场。
Adam's group absolutely takes a moral stand. A few times, he's found himself trying to convince potential members of the group that having sex with children is wrong. And occasionally, Adam has to turn someone away.
亚当的小组确实采取了道德立场。有几次，他发现自己在试图说服小组的潜在成员，与孩子发生性关系是错误的。偶尔，亚当不得不拒绝某些人。
There was one time someone came in, and he admitted to me pretty much right away that he'd done some sexual things with a five-year-old kid. And right then and there, I said we can't have you. First off, they're a risk. But what's more is I think, that I'll admit, I have a bias. I think we are better people than those who go out and hurt kids.
有一次有人进来了，他几乎立刻向我承认，他曾对一个5岁的孩子做过一些性行为。当场我就说我们不能要你。首先，他们是个风险。但更重要的是，我承认，我有偏见。我认为我们比那些去伤害孩子的人更好。
Did you tell him that?
你告诉他了吗？
I explained to him, you know, to the best of my ability, that what he did was very wrong. And that the most noble thing he could possibly do would be to tell the kid's parents so that at least that kid could get the help he might need.
我尽我所能向他解释说，他所做的事是非常错误的。而且他能做的最高尚的事就是告诉孩子的父母，以便那个孩子至少能得到他可能需要的帮助。
And what was his response?
他的反应是什么？
Something like maybe.
大概是“也许吧”之类的话。
In a different world, this person would be talking to a professional, not a 19-year-old with no training at all. Or maybe this person would just be in prison.
在另一个世界里，这个人会和专业人士交谈，而不是一个毫无训练的19岁年轻人。或者，也许这个人就应该呆在监狱里。
Here's another important distinction. Eight out of the nine in Adam's group say they are nonexclusive pedophiles, which means they are also attracted to their peers or adults, in addition to kids. That's important because researchers like Elizabeth Letourneau think it might be possible to push people like that to become more attracted to people their own age, if you start young.
这是另一个重要的区别。亚当小组的9个人中有8个说他们是非排他性恋童癖者，这意味着除了孩子之外，他们也受同龄人或成年人吸引。这很重要，因为像伊丽莎白·勒图诺这样的研究人员认为，如果你从年轻时就开始干预，可能有可能推动像这样的人变得对同龄人产生更多吸引力。
Yeah, so through hanging out with peers more often, engaging in fun things with peers more often, really increasing that, I really believe, at least for some kids, some portion of kids who are sexually attracted to children, it's changeable. I don't want to start with the premise that it's impossible.
是的，所以通过更频繁地与同龄人一起相处，更频繁地与同龄人一起进行有趣的活动，真正增加这一点，我真的相信，至少对一些孩子，对某些受儿童性吸引的孩子来说，这是可以改变的。我不想从“这是不可能的”这个前提开始。
When I first started talking to Letourneau a year and a half ago, she told me that in her 25 years in the field, she'd talked to lots of young guys who've abused children. But she'd never spoken to a pedophile who hasn't, which I found pretty incredible. I told her about Adam's group, and she asked if I could put them in touch. She's since spoken to several of them and has been talking to Adam regularly. And she's started to notice patterns, pattens that she can use to inform a treatment plan that she's getting off the ground.
当我一年半前第一次开始和勒图诺交谈时，她告诉我，在她25年的领域工作中，她和许多虐待过儿童的年轻人谈过话。但她从未和没虐待过儿童的恋童癖者交谈过，这让我觉得很不可思议。我告诉她亚当的小组，她问我能否联系上他们。此后她和他们中的几个人谈过，并一直在定期和亚当交流。她开始注意到一些模式，这些模式可以用来为她正在开展的治疗方案提供信息。
You know, before talking to Adam and the other young men, I didn't know when it really crystallized for them that this wasn't going away. I didn't know what the experiences were. I had no idea about the deep depression and the self-loathing and the fear that really characterized all of their adolescence.
你知道，在和亚当以及其他年轻人交谈之前，我不知道他们何时真正明确了这种吸引力不会消失。我不知道他们的经历是什么。我根本不知道深层的抑郁、自我厌恶和恐惧，这些确实是他们所有青春期的特征。
While Letourneau is just starting to learn about what causes pedophilia and develop methods for treatment, Adam doesn't agree that he can be fixed. He doesn't hold out hope for the possibility of becoming something other than a pedophile. It took him years to figure it out in the first place.
虽然勒图诺才刚刚开始了解导致恋童癖的原因并制定治疗方法，但亚当不同意他能被“治愈”。他不抱希望自己能变成恋童癖以外的人。他花了好几年才首先搞清楚这一点。
The truth is, I know what my attractions are. I know they're there. By every definition of the medical term, I am one. Sometimes, you really just know these things.
事实是，我知道我的吸引力是什么。我知道它们在那里。根据医学术语的每一个定义，我就是其中之一。有时，你确实就是知道这些事情。
Adam says being a pedophile is something he'll spend the rest of his life battling. But he's committed to managing it. He's thought ahead to his future in a way that most 19-year-olds don't.
亚当说，作为一名恋童癖者是他余生都要战斗的事情。但他致力于管理它。他以大多数19岁年轻人不会有的方式预想了自己的未来。
You know, I'd like a partner, obviously. The thought of having a kid is very scary. I'm not convinced I could ever allow myself to do that, as much as I may want it. I think, most people want kids at some point in their lives. And that's something that while I'm not saying I never will have, it's something I don't think I will have, I guess, for both of our safeties.
你知道，我显然想要个伴侣。想要个孩子的想法非常可怕。我不相信我能允许自己那样做，尽管我可能很想要。我想，大多数人在生命的某个阶段都想要孩子。而那件事，虽然我不是说我永远不会有，但我认为我不会拥有，我想，这是为了我们双方的安全。
Imagine being a teenager and being told never to act on your sexual feelings ever for the rest of your life. That's what we're asking of these people. At the moment, there is no clear plan for how to do that. But maybe there should be.
想象一下作为一个青少年，被告知余生都绝不能根据你的性感受去行动。这就是我们对这些人提出的要求。目前，没有明确的计划来执行这一点。但也许应该有。
Luke Malone. More of his reporting on this topic will appear next month on Medium.com.
卢克·马龙。他关于这一主题的更多报道将于下个月出现在Medium.com上。
[MUSIC - "FEEL LIKE A MONSTER" BY DEEPEST DARKEST]
（音乐 - 迪普斯特·达克斯特的《感觉像个怪物》）
Our program is produced today by Brian Reed with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffee-Walt, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Allison Davis. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our administrative assistant. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Research help from Michelle Harris and Julie Beer. Music help from Damien Graef, Rob Geddis, and Anthony Roman.
我们今天的节目由布莱恩·里德制作，亚历克斯·布伦伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、肖恩·科尔、斯蒂芬妮·福、查娜·乔菲-沃尔特、莎拉·柯尼格、米基·米克、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克共同参与。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。制作助理为艾莉森·戴维斯。塞思·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康顿是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森是我们的行政助理。阿德里安·马蒂奥维兹管理我们的网站。米歇尔·哈里斯和朱莉·比尔协助调研。达米恩·格拉夫、罗布·格迪斯和安东尼·罗曼提供音乐协助。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
（致谢）
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org, where, just a reminder, we have the photo of the man who was tarred and feathered this week. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Thanks, as always to our program's co-founder, Torey Malatia. He used to own an antique store, but it just didn't work out. Because he would say things to the customers like--
我们的网站ThisAmericanLife.org，提醒一下，我们那儿有本周那个被浇柏油粘羽毛的人的照片。《美国生活》由公共广播国际台发行。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚。他过去拥有一家古董店，但没经营下去。因为他会对顾客说这样的话——
"There's a difference in looking, and there is a difference in 'looooking.'"
“‘看’和‘打……量’是有区别的。”
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。公共广播国际台。